i
de lidia y una mujer es violada cada 16
minutos algunas lo son más que otras es
el caso de las mujeres conocidas como
intocables que pertenecen a la comunidad
la linda
el sistema de castas y que con
frecuencia son víctimas de las peores
atrocidades es la cama de mi hija aquí
dormía el 29 de mayo de 2020 y se llega
aquí la de recursos y ac milan dificulta
que el derecho a ley atea
aquella noche y la adolescente fue
sacada de su cama por tres hombres
pertenecientes a una casta superior
la metieron al bosque cercano a su casa
donde la violaron
la asesinaron este fue el lugar del
asesinato que quiera más sangrar o
cuando la descubrí mi hija estaba en muy
mal estado habían llegado sus ojos con
tierra tenían por toda la cara y también
tenía arañazos en el brazo su cabello
estaba enredado cuando la vi me volví
loco quite la bufanda que usaron para
ahorcarla y me la llevé en mis brazos
tras aceptar su crimen los victimarios
purgarán una corta pena dos ya fueron
liberados bajo fianza uno de ellos es un
vecino el padre de la víctima ya no cree
en la justicia
cuando hombres de una casta superior
violan o asesinan a alguien pasan tan
sólo dos o tres tal vez seis meses en
prisión antes de ser liberados estas
cosas no les ocurren a las chicas de
castas superiores tales como yadav
thakur o brahmanes
porque porque sólo les ocurre a las
chicas de dalit queremos justicia
queremos justicia para nuestra hija de
lo contrario para que vivan
el pasado mes de septiembre un asesinato
muy similar provocó una indignación
nacional y puso el foco en la condición
de las mujeres intocables
víctima de una violación colectiva lucho
por sobrevivir le cortaron la lengua le
quebraron la columna vertebral y le
fracturaron las piernas ella luchó pero
sucumbió a las heridas en medio de la
noche la policía decidió quemar el
cuerpo de la joven mujer el cuerpo de la
víctima fue quemado antes de que una
investigación pudiese tener lugar para
proteger a los asesinos de casta
superior un sistema social fuente de
injusticia para esta abogada reconocida
por defender los derechos de la dalit
las castas están tan enraizadas en la
sociedad india que cada una de nosotras
nacemos y morimos en la misma casa las
relaciones de poder impiden la abolición
de este sistema porque aquellos que
tienen privilegios dinero poder no
quieren perder los entonces no respetan
la ley
es tan difícil obtener justicia cuando
se es una mujer de la casa de las placas
a pesar de las dificultades cada vez más
mujeres de alix lucha para cambiar las
cosas
militante abogada y madre de dos hijos
salida se dio por visión dar una voz a
la mujer en salida de la sociedad más
justa para sus propios hijos de hecho su
rabia y su vocación surgieron en una
salida escolar en el templo
el cura me pregunto a qué comunidad
pertenecía entonces le dije qué quiere
decir con ello y me preguntó del
apellido de mi padre yo era muy pequeña
para entender el sistema de castas en
aquella época le contesté y me dijo que
no volviera nunca exclamó tu casa no
puede entrar en este templo lo mantenía
para salir de haber mal la lucha por los
derechos de las mujeres de leeds
requiere del apoyo de todas las mujeres
el trabajo agrícola el aseo las tareas
ingratas el aseo de los baños es todo lo
que hacen las mujeres del ics
y no encontrar a una sola mujer de casta
superior en estos empleos
las mujeres de leeds necesitan
cooperación de las mujeres de otras
castas debemos dialogar
la abogada defiende gratuitamente a las
víctimas de casta inferior en su región
natal ra gastar
primero destrozaron la puerta con una
hacha
[Música]
y pues entre 10 u 11 personas trataron
de quebrar el cerrojo frágil e
ingresaron estas mujeres atacadas en
medio de la noche pertenecen al hogar
del ipd de su pueblo los vecinos de
castas superiores quieren obligarla a
abandonar el terreno la policía rechazó
la denuncia tras la agresión hay muy
pocos oficiales de policía provenientes
de la comunidad dalit en las comisarías
en general hay policías de casta
superior y no quieren perjudicar la
reputación de su propia comunidad en
promedio 10 mujeres de casta inferior
son violadas diariamente en india y
numerosos casos no son notificados no
sirve de nada irse de su hogar no es la
solución
este tipo de personas están por todas
partes si necesitan me ayuda incluso en
medio de la noche
yo me desplazaría
las castas están profundamente
enraizadas en la sociedad india hasta en
el sistema judicial la lucha por la
igualdad sea de largo aliento